can we talk sure okay
okay hi how are you good evening
[Music]
Milton has a type I have here thick
sassy sense of humor is there anything
else you want to add to that checklist
that's about it so what are you for work
I'm a school bus driver oh
damn that was quick
and look at each other
he took one Lookers like [ __ ] you could
have gone quicker with your fat ass
no no no
if you would have rejected me because
I'm a bus driver you getting this work
I'm about to ride over you with this bus
what
why are you I'm mad for the homie I
could see that yeah you got poor shaped
yes so it's time left handshake I'm
exactly yes living in your truth yes
shame shame I want a shame forever
don't matter if you're a thick shame you
took me out cause I'm a bus driver I'm
sick I know right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
ask her why did you reject me why did
you I just wasn't feeling the sparked
[Music]
the spike was in the bus that he's
driving every day and this part is there
you didn't want that he's just a bus
driver now it go wait a minute it goes
what the [ __ ] I was telling you about
whatever who what does it look like when
you make a 100k
it looked like a suitcase even if he was
a bus driver that was that owned three
buses yeah that had drivers on him and
he was actually driving one of them yeah
right making well over 100k because he
had to end contracts right but he's also
driving the bus because he's about that
paper yeah bus driver don't sound like a
100K so on that other video when all the
girls get all these wild numbers it's
also what the [ __ ] look like
because there's a romance to it yeah but
she heard bus driver what was she
thinking hey no you you oh I don't want
to see you wear them jeans with the
holes every day and why are you driving
kids you probably a fog you know I mean
you probably diddle them okay there's
all the but there's all those thoughts
hi I am really open to trying anything
new I'm pretty new to the area butt
stuff
all right
juvenile you know that yeah yes look at
us
I mean I'm 40 but going on 12. yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you the
opposite of fresh yeah yeah he 28 going
on 80. and you 40 going on the 11th yeah
I just started a new job recently and I
work in the beer industry
at bars and things like that so he was
like looking like the bad [ __ ] of beer
girl did she say bee
so when you're dating what age group do
you normally kind of stick to Bro
there's about to be the this is about
this is about to be the kill one yeah he
said what age group and he about to fall
outside because he looks like he's 37
and she looks like she's 45. she'll look
like she's 22. that's not great hair I
usually go older so my age range is
usually like 22 to 32 kind of thing
oh when I tell you what did I tell you
she said 22 to what
32. that means she says older so that
means she's around 22. yeah she's about
she's about no she's young as well but I
mean ouch okay yeah God damn sorry girl
I thought you were a lot older than that
I'm at the bottom of that I'm 39. okay I
am so so sorry how are we doing you know
I'm great thanks for getting off my feet
move around a little bit yeah yo you got
his hands ready he went yeah so how we
doing stop drop and exit recommend
anyone watch the show okay
sorry
it was bound to happen
it was about to happen he would sorry no
the way you hit that bro you were going
for the job but shout outs to aggressive
slam no worries I didn't say sorry
you're a lovely thank you um but
you're lovely I don't need to take them
off I felt you already when I gave you
that hug we good you're lovely thank you
um girl you have one of the most
gorgeous [ __ ] I don't ever see I mean
the way the sunlight hugs your curves I
done seen your silhouette in my dreams
the way that the
booty touch the cheek the way that the
thigh connects to the knee count I mean
listen I'm not even gonna front you uh I
think you might be one of the most
beautiful IG models I don't ever I don't
have Instagram man don't answer with the
attractions from the reaction that I'm
having to your actions in terms of the
clothes that you chose I felt that the
way that you left your Abode you came
through with the freshness girl I ain't
compare you to Friendship fit but I'm
saying that you came with the right fit
you'll feel Me Abba Zaba Zulu the third
seeing what can't be heard I done had
Vision since I was blind cause now I see
the truth call me the red pill girl I'm
about to give you the real deal oh
damn [ __ ] your skin is smooth
how you doing
yeah oh oh you just let me grab you like
that damn come over here oh you
submissive okay
girl you gorgeous was it the Riverdale
I'm gonna be very candid with you we
have a little bit of a bromance back
there and so I kind of
you needed to be out yeah
I just wanted to hear it oh no I just
heard a big gas from the gal room what
the other this has went from a social
dating experiment to [ __ ] gangs women
yeah yeah yo male face
[Laughter]
period blood I think I'm not villain
number one hi I'm Nathan Hello nice to
meet you it's nice to meet you I'm Sam
Samantha how are you doing today
um I'm doing good what is something that
you watch by yourself that's a guilty
pleasure that you don't tell anybody I
mean I watch a lot of anime no [ __ ]
how did I knew I mean she came in
dressed like a Bleach character
it's me and she started talking too much
I'd probably pull out the Bankai as well
and tell her to shut the [ __ ] up she's a
Bleach character yeah oh yeah yeah I
don't mean the fact that she's white I
mean the design
s
I
think me too a lot of Asian shows like
Korean dramas what is your type I'm
definitely very into Asian men
what race do you think I am I have no
idea I don't I don't want to make
assumptions you want to take a guess I
would say like maybe white to Asian
maybe I'm Asian cool yeah
can we talk sure okay
okay hi how are you good evening
[Music]
my allergies are fair enough
that's how cringy it is
I don't know what this man's name is
you know listen bro I don't know what
this guy's name is but I want to
appreciate how this guy is gaming the
system
he said we blindfolded it but
if I can't see you with my eyes I'ma see
you with my hands
oh triple D titties
large waist she fat
oh my God
hey man hey man my man is hugging for a
purpose yeah and it ain't to show you
love it's to find out if he wants to
make love to you yeah and the answer is
no bars why Nathan we get along on a lot
of different topics but I felt that it
was something where I could become a
really good friend with you yeah yeah I
felt your body and I'm like friend zone
imagine someone hugging you be like I
think we're better off as friends yes
friends
I think we're I I think all of this and
I are better office that's what he's
saying that in different words I think
so and different work I'm saying get
clear-cut I'm translating what he said
yeah that's just kind of a gut feeling
for me no that's totally totally valid
yeah yeah so this went viral on Twitter
the video we watched I want you to read
Nathan the dude that buzzed her hugged
every single girl that sat down and when
he realized they were fat he immediately
pressed the buzzer this dude is actually
just fat phobic or that's just not they
type
like you don't have to want to date
everybody time like would you date if
you're a guy that it's in into girls
right would you
be
a woman that is like IVF Pro
bodybuilding you mean Super Body but she
built like she got dealts and [ __ ] yeah
and everything else packs packs decks
next you know I mean everything is all
would you depends does she have dicks no
okay but let's
if the body top is not your thing that's
what that's not your thing even men even
if you're a woman and and your woman and
you date men right
ibf Pro
some girls some girls told me I look at
our guys like oh that that's too much so
how can it be too much when we're
talking about muscles
but when we talk about other things for
some people it's not too much that's you
okay
so too much muscles you could say that
and that's fine nobody bats a knife guy
or girl
but when we talk about other things like
uh too much hair oh you're gonna have to
do something about that I've seen girls
when we go at the beach guy has a back
full of hair that's too much I'm gonna
have to do something about that
heterophobia hair is fine
but other things is not man and woman
men and women there's a whole movement
called I don't remember what it is but
you let your your your your your your
your hair grow and everything except for
women that's fine
man with this [ __ ] on their back that's
fun that's not that disgusting that's a
bit too much oh
okay so why is it too much for some
things but for other things it's not
I don't care
I actually don't care are they big are
they small I would date muscular I do
not care I don't but it's a good
question to ask why why in some cases it
is too much and some don't and it goes
with whatever Baba was saying on another
video he's saying uh we protect certain
people in certain people it's like yeah
so when it's I'm just saying I said what
I said about I'm about to just repeat it
but I'm just asking the question out
there answer that at least at least
he's going with the rule he can't see
he's hugging that's not my [ __ ] that's
not the [ __ ] that goes that makes me go
off
yo I was having a discussion what [ __ ]
what's with that smile this is the best
take you've had all year ever I don't
ever but it's up there top three oh I'd
say oh yo everybody write that [ __ ]
down cause you gonna use that in your
robotics anytime everyone brings up fat
phobia write this [ __ ] down go ahead I
said what I said
so whenever you got someone that is
super muscular guy or girl and you look
at them you're like oh no that's too
much
it's okay to say that's too much muscle
but when it's other thing it's not too
much when we see too much hair you're
like oh that's that's too much a whole
that's Grizzly out there that we could
say that and that's fine but other
things we can yo and let me also say
this this is the same home girl who said
what is your type I'm definitely very
into Asian men uh she has a fetish for
like Asian dudes that's no huh
who that what what was that no I don't
do [ __ ] okay I don't hear [ __ ] she
literally you can't I lied about it she
really borderline borderline because
it's not proven borderline because it
could have been that confessed to a
fetish I mean hey bro she likes anime
she came in dressed as an anime
character and then she says that but no
nothing we're not gonna go but that's
fine
that's fine
no we're just gonna yeah that's that guy
cannot reject her he's fat phobic oh
I don't know you put it out there maybe
he's both maybe he's both but the
original question is this
why why one is okay to be too much and
other things are not like I said I do
not care I don't mind big big I don't
mind small smile either but it's a weird
question
hey how are you I'm good how are you
good my name is Nathan what's your name
I'm Amy
why did you press the button it's just
like was it the vibe
okay I'm 21. okay Amy is dating to Mary
are you ready to get married Donovan
I don't mind marriage I really don't I
just it depends how like smells how old
are you I am 26 probably when you look
at me though you're probably like no
younger than that younger really okay my
man looks like a bug's bunny Villa
Elmer [ __ ] that's just like
did it
foreign
you ever had too much water in your
mouth
but it got too much teeth in the smell
and that's it overflowing only ones
three kids three is a little too much
I got it two would be fine three is like
like you don't make enough wow
oh get this [ __ ] out of here get this
[ __ ] out of here
my name is Ria okay my name is Donovan
what is your type look wise my type my
husband all over the board I definitely
love people who are like athletic and
into the gym I love like manly men who
can like you know let me feel more
relaxed and like so that's my type yeah
I do work out and everything so it's
just part of my regimen I do it right
how to fill your arms
where are your arms
literally listen he might have said
worked out I'm like what you do teeth
curls because that [ __ ] is
before head curls we all got our
strengths you know what I'm saying we
all got her before we're working out
right now because your voice
we've been lifting these carrying you
through these videos [ __ ] let me carry
you through these videos this Ethiopian
Powerhouse
the Horn of Africa carrying all my
semi-people Florida
right let's go forehead press yay I can
take I receive it so I gotta do [ __ ]
every time somebody yeah I mean some
people gotta catch a few strikes
forehead deadlifts and there's no way
that this girl when she thinks of
athletic attractive man she's thinking
of this foreheads quads yeah I guarantee
you she gets a chance to look at him
she'll say no but I'm guessing she's
what do you like to work out in the gym
so honestly I work out every particular
muscle twice a week I would say my
favorite one I like to do is chest where
is that it's right there can I feel your
face go ahead go ahead okay
[Music]
that [ __ ] so quick yeah for my face
[Laughter]
feel my face yeah yeah give me two
seconds all right that [ __ ]
I would say my favorite one I like to do
is chest where is that it's right there
I would have been so hilarious if he's
like
now let me feel your chest
[Music]
I mean like listen I was back kind
expected why did you reject him
um I just want to see like what other
Vibes are there it's for the experience
so this is woman ease for
um you ugly
ugly you ain't got no alibi and I can do
way better so I'm gonna do better next
hello hi hi I'm Devonte do you like the
smell of each other a little whiff thank
you
yeah I mean I don't know you smell like
body wash I hope so
this is the one they definitely gonna
feel each other yeah oh that's a nice
person what is that lotion it's a bum
bum cream it has cream what is that
that's crazy I don't know what bum bum
cream is but I know what bum bum cream
sounds like Hey listen
man you spray it on the wheels oh that's
what you like it I thought it was uh I'm
into anal
what stuff
that's what I thought it was if you went
the other way you went digging in the
butthole like treasure hunting
bum bum cream oh that's bum bum cream
cream
I gotta moisturize some cheeks you know
yeah what are you doing after this I
don't know what are you about you you're
trying to find out I'm quite certain you
are going to be suffering very soon eh
someone's anus is going to be ruptured
are you ready to see each other yeah
three two one I've got herpes
the craziest juxtaposition between
someone seeing someone very sexy and
then finally got like this
okay oh my god oh you're cute
yeah I like the eye monitor with the
blue yeah you have a really nice smile
okay are you gonna commit to a second
date
yo this dude is such a [ __ ] boy it's
crazy but it's working for him so shout
outs to him congratulations do your
thing get it in player second day
the lady's comfortable with it I am yeah
I would enjoy that congratulations
you've won the button why
it's a pleasure okay I'm glad I skipped
the person before this
bruh you already gave him an L you keep
letting somebody else catch us straight
Gotta Give two Hells oh my God God damn
do you have any idea how many teeth
curls he's gonna do now leave him alone
you spout loser with one L not little
sir what the [ __ ] this is an origin
story this is how Batman villains are
created the penguin this is how it
happened this is teeth man Bros let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you